we gotta kick up that flavor just a
little bit for very little money and i
know some chefs and foodies are like
that looks a hotness i know please
hi i'm ayo and i'm a private show
typically when i work for clients i have
a really big or unlimited budget but
tasty is challenging me to create a
three-course meal for four guests for
twenty dollars which honestly feels like
a little bit of a setup wish me luck
so for the first course i'm gonna set my
oven to 425 and i'm actually going to
crisp up this prosciutto i found for
four dollars so we have a nice crunchy
topping that gives our tartine some
depth and some texture next i got the
bread for one dollar and i'm gonna make
the base of the tartine by covering both
sides of the bread in olive oil and also
toasting it in the oven with the
prosciutto to save time so the
prosciutto is gonna go in the oven for
about six minutes and the toast are
going to go in the oven for anywhere
between seven to ten minutes while those
are in the oven we're going to make our
whipped lemon ricotta first we're going
to put the ricotta into the food
processor a lot of food processors need
some kind of liquid or something in the
bottom to get them going so i'm going to
add my tablespoon of olive oil pretty
close to the blade
good good good tip is to use one
ingredient twice so for this step i'm
actually only going to use the zest of
this lemon and i'll use the juice later
so i'm going to add a little salt and
then i'm going to start this bad boy
i'm actually going to let this sit for a
second and move on to getting my
zucchini ready for our presentation i'm
actually going to create zucchini
ribbons which will give us a little
height too and this is what you want for
your peel so i'm going to season these
with pepper and i'm going to add a
little salt because everything needs a
little salt and just a hint of olive oil
because it's going to make them easier
to twirl and basically you're just going
to give it a little toss it doesn't need
a lot and you want to be really gentle
with them because you can overwork the
zucchini and then they just get watery
and they get really flat and we want to
keep that crunch and that height i'm
going to go get my toast and my
prosciutto and let's put together course
number one so the first thing you're
going to want to do with your hot bread
is rub it with fresh garlic cloves and i
know if you've never done this it's like
what but this gives it so much flavor
hold on tight to the garlic and keep
rubbing it and you want to do that to
all of them both sides we're going to
take about two tablespoons of ricotta
and just scoop a big dollop right in the
middle and i know some chefs and foodies
are like that looks a hot mess i know
that is why we have this and i'm
actually just gonna create some nice
little hills and valleys for my bikini
to live in all right so our next step is
definitely like the show stopper of this
course so what you're going to do for
your ribbon take a little piece you can
wrap it around a finger
or a pair of tweezers if you're that
kind of chef and you have them i am that
kind of chef i have them and when you
make the curl you just slide it off you
just want to create a little ribbon and
when you put it down it just stays
and basically we're going to do that two
to three more times for each toast we're
going to take half of one piece of our
prosciutto and we're just going to give
it a little crumble and once you have a
couple little pieces you're just going
to lightly sprinkle them over your
zucchini toast so after the prosciutto
we're going to top it with some parsley
i'm going to use italian parsley never
curly do not buy curly parsley i don't
know why they sell it it's literally
grass please so the parsley is pretty
much our last step so i'm just going to
salt and pepper it and then we can move
on to our main course and the great
thing about this one is this thing came
in at
and 21 cents i honestly couldn't believe
it
so for my chicken filling i have a half
a cup of spinach a cup of shredded
mozzarella cheese and a little bit of
minced garlic about one clove okay so
i've mixed up our filling we're just
going to set this aside and we're going
to start pounding out this chicken when
you're pounding out chicken two very
important things
plastic wrap you want one on the bottom
and one on the top and basically this is
just going to protect your chicken from
flying everywhere it's going to protect
everything around you when you're
pounding it out you want to get it about
a quarter of an inch thick and if you do
get a hole or two don't worry about it
because that is what the prosciutto is
here for it's really great stress
reliever too all right and i think we
are about there i'm actually going to go
ahead and season my chicken thigh and i
use the style because styles are always
much cheaper than brushed so our chicken
is seasoned and pounded out i'm going to
get a new piece of plastic wrap and lay
two pieces of prosciutto down i'm just
gonna lay my chicken down inside the
prosciutto and then we're gonna add our
filling and i'm gonna make sure i create
a thin layer all across so you get an
equal amount of cheese and spinach in
one bite tuck your thumbs under the
bottom and you just create a nice tight
roll all the way and if you get a little
filling on the side you know just shove
it back in everyone's going to go
together the good thing about putting
the plastic wrap down first is we're
already ready so i'm actually going to
take the end furthest away from me and
just really tightly roll her up and what
this does is gets the chicken kind of
used to being in this shape and it makes
it a lot easier when it comes time to
sear it
we're sharing them so we can help the
prosciutto get crispy we're going to
lock in our moisture before we put it in
the oven and i'm going to create a
little bit of pond at the bottom of the
pan which basically means we're going to
get a little bit of brown bit so when we
deglaze it to make our sauce it'll have
a little bit of the meat flavor which
just helps tie the whole dish together
so this is what we want this is golden
brown delicious since i got that on one
side i'm just going to turn them so i
can keep getting
all my five nice and brown
so these are about ready i actually
added some toothpicks because they
started on roll a little bit so i'm
going to take these out and transfer
them to this pan so we can put them in
the oven for about 15 to 20 minutes at
400 degrees so now we're going to make
our sauce we're going to slice our
peppers so what you're going to do is
just split it in half down the middle
you want to remove the seeds and the
membranes because when we create our red
pepper sauce they're just going to make
it gritty so roasting the pepper is a
really good idea for this sauce because
it's going to give us a ton of flavor it
completely changes the flavor profile of
the pepper for very very little money
very little money so let's go broil
these for two to three minutes once the
skin is nice and black it's time for
them to come out so my peppers are done
i put them in this bowl and wrap them so
it steams them and that skin is just
going to melt off we're going to blend
this so you don't really need it to be
like a nice chop to create more depth of
flavor first we're going to saute this
pepper we're also going to add two
cloves of minced garlic smells great so
now i'm gonna deglaze this with our
lemon juice so when we say deglaze it
literally means pick up all the brown
bits or anything that could be stuck to
the pan so i have a cup and a half of
chicken broth i'm gonna add that to my
sauce before we get to blanking all
right so this looks ready so i'm just
gonna pour it in the blender
so i'm gonna go ahead and add this back
to our pan and i know this feels like a
lot of steps for a sauce but to me the
sauce is the most important part so now
we're just going to let this come up to
a boil and we're going to turn it down a
little so it doesn't boil over but you
do want it to reduce by about half so
this is reduced so i think we're good to
go the only thing we're missing for this
is something to give it like that
luxurious feel which is where the butter
comes in so i am going to add this very
very cold butter about a tablespoon
tablespoon and a half at a time because
you do not want to break your sauce
which is a very technical way of saying
your thoughts are screwed so once one of
them has melted into your pan and it
looks good at the next one
this looks beautiful but i mean what
what doesn't look beautiful after having
six tablespoons of butter in it come on
for this dish i'm using fettuccine so
basically i'm just gonna give it a nice
little twirl in the sauce all right
let's see what this inside looks like oh
that that is sexy 20 bucks you can't you
cannot be mad at this so as you can see
when i get into my pasta i just start
creating like just a little twirl and
i'm just going to put it directly in the
center and just drop it and because we
spent all that time making these pretty
rolls we're gonna stagger them so you
can see all of the pieces
all we need is a little italian parsley
and finally we're gonna put some fresh
cracked black pepper over the top and
that's our main course surprisingly it
came in at 189 per serving and it looks
amazing i'm excited so let's go ahead
and start on dessert
the first thing i'm going to do is take
a teaspoon and a half of this gelatin
and i'm just gonna add the gelatin to
the water and then we're gonna let it
sit for about five minutes while that's
happening we're gonna add our half and
half and our sugar and then i'm just
gonna give it a little stir while i
bring it up just under a boil i'm gonna
add our gelatin to it and i'm just gonna
keep stirring it so now we're gonna
strain it and it's just to make sure we
don't get any little bits of gelatin or
anything and make sure it has a nice
creamy mouth feel once our cream has
cooled down a little bit i'm gonna add
it to our cups they're gonna sit at a
really cool angle just another little
plating trick to make them look a little
fancier than they actually are
i have a pound of thawed frozen
strawberries and i'm gonna add them to
my pan and with them i'm going to add a
quarter cup of sugar and a half a cup of
water i'm going to do this until they
come up just under a boil so they have a
nice bubble to them until some of the
water comes out of the strawberries and
we're just going to puree it
oh it smells so good this is beautiful
so i'm just going to put this back we're
going to keep it warm because we're
going to add back in our gelatin all
right this is good to go so i'm going to
go ahead and strain it got some chunky
bits some seeds all the things from the
strawberries so i think we got it all
out and we are ready to set i've
transferred my strawberry puree to a
measuring cup and i'm just going to pour
it over the white part you need to let
this cool a little bit you don't want to
do it while it's hot so i'm going to let
these sit for two to four hours and hope
that i was able to make this pretty and
tasty because that's really the true
test of this right it needs to taste
good and not like it costs 20
all right that's our strawberry panna
cotta came in at 106
per serving which is insane like i think
it's beautiful so for 20 i was able to
create a super seasonal tartine there's
a roasted red pepper sauce i wrapped my
chicken in the same prosciutto and
finally we made this awesome panna cotta
i'm actually really proud of this you
guys i think i did a pretty good job
okay this is really good
i cannot believe this was a dollar and
six cents it tastes like we really put
some effort for it like like me and
y'all we did this together thank you
guys for watching amayo cherry if you
want more of me you can always follow me
on instagram let us know in the comments
what else you think we should make
please try this cause it actually came
out super good so i think you guys would
enjoy it bye
i'm gonna eat some more of this this is
really good
oh yes
[Music]
you